Ivanova Steve Kaufman here again to talk
about language learning and today I'm
gonna talk about call it the strategy of
listening or the strategic nature of
listening from a number of different
perspectives and these are a number of
thoughts that have been kind of going
through my mind as I continue listening
to my Arabic and Persian you know
learning a language is a long distance
run so we have to have a strategy
there are might be sort of short-term
tactics but you have to have a strategy
for the long haul and to me the most
strategic thing we do is listen
listening and listening comprehension is
at the core of everything when I read in
another language I have to hear the
language I have to be able to sub
vocalize this is particularly true when
I read in languages like Arabic and
Persian where at least as yet to me it's
not immediately obvious how the words
are pronounced it was certainly too true
when I was learning Chinese I had to
have a sort of a level of listening
comprehension I have to hear the words
in order to be able to read them and the
reading activity or the activity that I
do reading on my iPad using link to
acquire words is all sort of a tactic to
aid in my main strategy and my main
strategic goal which is to achieve a
high level of listening comprehension
but of course I'm able to retain the
words better if I read them if I see
them and then I hear them so I need the
reading in order to make the listening
comprehensible and sometimes people ask
for how do you start listening if you
don't know anything well that's one of
the magic moments in language learning
by doing the mini stories for example a
lot of material with a lot of repetition
and a lot of basic you know
high-frequency verbs you know languages
like for me was the case with Turkish
and Persian and Arabic and Greek which
are just noise through
relative listening they start to have
meaning and so you get a toehold but
once you're through the holes and I'd
listen to my sixty many stories in
Persian Arabic and so forth thirty forty
fifty times I can't continue listening
to them even though I I still have
little areas where I've forgotten worse
I got a move on
so then strategically I move on to in
the case of Arabic podcast from mostly
cause bad cut and in the case of Persian
to the far door podcasts that are put
out by the Radio Free Europe people but
there it's difficult however I noticed
just by listening I understand more and
more not just by listening because I
also invest the time in reading and
listening and saving words so that now
the promise that Kat podcasts have
fifteen to twenty percent unknown words
whereas it used to be forty percent so
even though probably I'm I don't speak
that much better I understand more I
notice more words that I know when I'm
listening and so and so it's all focused
on this this sort of listening
comprehension one of the things that
I've started doing and which I want to
mention and get some reaction from
people is on the Persian I was able to
find people in Iran in my case an
Iranian person who's been traveling in
India to create these stories where they
talk about themselves whatever they're
doing things that interest them what
they've done in life what they study and
so that you're five minutes long seven
minutes long they speak them first then
they transcribe them we have these in
Persian it's called the Iranians and
it's quite interesting there's I think
sixteen or seventeen stories but then I
had them convicted as one collaborator
creates stories excuse me create
questions the way we do for the many
stories now I always against being asked
questions about things that I have read
or listened to that is if I am asked to
try to remember and say in my own words
what happened in the story however I
think it's tremendously
official to be asked to be told the
answer then ask the question and then
get the answer again so for example if
the story is about you know sera who
travels in India and visited a yoga
clinic is something that the statement
might be Sarah spent five days in the
yoga clinic in Pune that's the statement
the question is did Sarah spend ten days
in the yoga clinic in Pune and then the
answer is no Sarah didn't spend ten days
she spent five days so I don't to think
of anything I don't have to remember
anything
the answer is there but I have to answer
either yes or no or when or where or how
type of questions where the answers are
largely there so it's it's kind of
exposure and these are tremendous
because you're really able to focus in
on that particular bit of vocabulary so
now I'm thinking with the falsified cat
like originally when I had these stories
done I hadn't thought of adding these
questions to them now that I've asked
SAR not to do the questions and answers
and I find it very beneficial now I'm
thinking it would be an interesting
experiment I don't know if there are
Arabic speakers out there that would be
interested in helping me on this where
you take I say a constant cat podcast
which might be about the situation in
Palestine or in Libya or the different
things that elections in Algeria
whatever they're talking about are in
France bad kept in Arabic and come up
with ten statements okay
recently in you know the reaction to the
Trump so-called deal of the century in
the Arab world has been mostly negative
that's a statement now the question is
has the reaction to the Trump deal of
the century and to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict being well
received received in the Arab world as a
question the answer no it has not been
well-received it has largely not been
well received
so that then is taking something that
was said in the podcast turning it into
a statement question answer and having
10 of these or 20 for that matter
because some of these podcasts are quite
long and some of these I got to be very
careful with these Arabic podcast
discussions because if there are three
or four people they're guaranteed
they're all gonna be talking at the same
time and it's very difficult to hear
what they're saying
I gotta get full marks to the
transcriber who is able to sort out
who's saying what so it's best if
there's only two because then at least
you know you have a better chance of
having only one person talking at once
but that's okay so the point is there's
again a strategy visa be improving my
listening comprehension and so I'm gonna
be doing more of that you'll be able to
find these at length of course and we
have one person who is helping us on the
Persian if I'm gonna have to try and
look for someone who can do the same on
the Arabic and I want to experiment
going into my podcasts which are largely
on political subjects and then
extracting say ten statements with the
corresponding question and then the
corresponding answer and all of this is
to build up my listening comprehension
so that and so ultimately for me okay
the goal in learning a language is to
speak obviously but I know from
experience that if I understand well if
I understand these political podcasts if
I understand movies like my wife wife is
watching this the resurrection Turkish
serial on Netflix and I've kind of
dropped my Turkish but if I can
understand everything they were saying I
will be able to speak I may speak poorly
at first but very quickly I will catch
up because all of that passive
vocabulary all of that solid listening
comprehension capability will activate
so that strategically the goal of
language meaning of seven support and
they should do it in schools as well
should be comprehension listening
comprehension and the speaking ability
will come with the need or the
opportunity as long as the person is
willing to
go for it and not worry about making
mistakes so there you have it the
strategic importance of listening as a
sort of the key element the key
strategic goal of 30 of my language
learning and some discussion about the
use of these statement question-answer
techniques in order to make you know
these things that I'm listening to that
are now kind of a little difficult for
me as I go from the many stories to you
know genuine authentic content that a
way to make those more comprehensible is
to create these you know statement
question answer you know
bits of content where you're gonna get
more repetition of some of the key okay
so that's kind of what was running
through my mind I am going to be
pursuing this idea I'm getting these
statements legend answers attached to
some of the podcasts that we have in our
library at length and yeah thank you and
I look forward to your comments
[Music]